hi I'm Sydney I'm a modern writer hi I'm
Millie I'm a blogger and mother from
Hull and we're here to talk about
anxiety the first time I ever felt
anxiety was in primary school and it was
that kind of moment where you late to a
class and you walk in and everybody's
already sat down they know that place
and you're just stood there and
everybody just stares and it's almost
like it's like deafeningly loud silence
and everything just rushes to your brain
you've got climbing hands you just
devastated to be in that situation and
then you fear ever having to move school
again because I've recently had like a
problem with making plans and if they're
quite far enough in advance so they said
their week in advance I like kind of be
thinking about it everyone that like the
first couple of days and then it like
becomes quite obsessive obsessive force
about it and so eventually like it's two
hours before I meant to do something and
I've worked myself up into such a
commotion that I then like pull out or I
have like a panic attack
I was like yeah like how many ones of
you cancel yeah anxiety like stuff that
I desperately want to date and it comes
like half an hour and I'm like I'm going
to bed yeah this can't do it yeah too
much yeah rather fill out but you've
done that to yourself like we've worked
ourselves up to this morning like it
could have been really straightforward
with our anxiety but it's noise yeah I
hit certain points of trauma in my life
and from then anxiety just kind of
escalated with it as like a way of
cushioning the trauma it was kind of
like my safety blanket but it's affected
pretty much every period of my life I
don't think I've had one experience or
one day that hasn't been affected by
anxiety I don't know about you I don't
if you've kind of like if it's got worse
over a period of time or I think I was
just a born warrior I worried about
everything since I can remember and I'd
be worrying throughout school day about
the sleepover like coming up and like
preparing myself for it and what if I
couldn't get to sleep what if we have a
girl fell asleep first and then it would
just kind of gets us frightened I just
start panicking for me when I was around
13 I started understanding how to
self-medicate these worries and when I
discovered
alcohol's party and i and that obviously
opened up a few more issues for me over
the year has it's the irony of getting
anxious about being anxious so like
thinking about the first time you're
anxious you then like so anxious for
that feeling to come back so you're
anxious about being anxious which makes
you mine yes it's ridiculous
I get pins and needles and I get clammy
hands I don't know who you like I get
it's kind of tunnel vision where I can't
see beyond I just can't see the room I
walk into anywhere and I'm just
overwhelmed yeah that's it over one yeah
when I realized I needed the help I went
to my GP at first and stuff too like
looking online and things like I
couldn't find anything I was actually
helping and I was like I can't do this
myself and we're I into Google like ways
to cope with anxiety and like the silly
thing is I wrote what is anxiety because
I was like is this even anxiety that I'm
feeling because you don't hear anybody
talk about it in like the physical sense
anymore or like people just say like I'm
a bit anxious to go someone I think the
meanings gone Zak yeah yeah like the me
no it's gone but like I actually went to
my GP for help and just kind of said
like this isn't okay anymore like I need
help with this and he kind of like
referred like CBT counseling like CBT is
been great so it's like cognitive
behavioral therapy and it's where like
if you know you're doing some things to
say like if I'm starting to feel like
just old fiddle and I like that's when I
know because I'm feeling yeah making you
anxious thinking right and I like I'll
fiddle like this and it teaches you to
recognize at the very beginning and
interject with coping mechanism it's so
cliche but I use like the anxiety apps
on my phone I haven't done this I've
heard so much about it it's like so like
what the headspace no yeah yeah they
have like circles where you like brew
you thin time with the circles and I
found that just focusing on something
silly like that takes your mind off what
you're actually worrying about yeah so
you don't have that buildup of worry I
tried Transcendental Meditation Wow yeah
I mean I really at first I was doing so
I've met it's kind of they teach you to
meditate for it to 20 minutes a day
yeah for me it was just quite a lot I
did it and and at first it was really
helpful cuz it just like gives you that
kind of time out of your year of that
overthinking thing it breaks the cycle
yeah and it gives you that space to kind
of like calm down yeah so I'm like
taking satchel een for anxiety now and I
coffee or the mental health comes to but
it really helps with the anxiety you
know I reacted so badly to it and for me
I think because the doctor didn't the
dogs didn't really kind of explain what
I was taking it was kind of it was it
didn't really do a background check even
so I was unlike where I was in myself so
I was drinking a lot taking those drugs
and then I was getting searching in
which made me feel even more numb there
just kind of like through I know it had
though it's a solution to the mirror and
it was just kind of added for a bigger
man yeah whereas now I'm kind of like
using this actually and it's like an
addition to the therapy not was just
like a quick fix it's kind of like got a
little pick-me-up that I need in
addition to thank you after you started
therapy or before so I thought it was
just gonna be this instant fix
started but it's an all you need to work
with it I think now we're very much more
aware of anxiety and we can say oh I've
got anxiety whereas I think when I was
growing up it wasn't so much of a thing
to say well I'm like it was kind of I
mean I was I was just feeling all these
things and I didn't know what it was I
think also it's like because because
there's that kind of approach with
anxiety which is I just kind of get on
with it like you just forget about yeah
but but that can also mean that you
don't seek the help you need and it's
like I feel like if you go into a
doctor's office and you're wearing
makeup and you've got clothes on and you
dressed up then what you're for like I
always feel like I need to go in on a
day where I don't look good in pieces
and then you take me seriously but it's
kind of like oh you're a young girl you
just anxious about like the world about
boys and it's like no this is ruining my
life right now like take me seriously
but whose eye is this something that
affects women more than it does really
people need to realize that it's a
spectrum like you're not always a
anxiety sometimes you're dealing with it
okay but you're still anxious you still
a person who suffers from anxiety what
advice would you give you a younger self
that it's going to be okay if I could go
back and tell my 13 year old self to go
out and enjoy every second and not care
about what I look like not care about
what I might say not care about what the
pictures look like I do in a heartbeat
it's very easy to say that though it's
so easy to say that like would I be here
if I didn't have those experiences it's
you know it's soon some roundabouts
isn't it but what would you tell
yourself I think I told myself not to
that I can't control everything around
me and that that's okay that's okay I
think you have to surrender some control
and let things just happen and all you
can do is kind of look at what you're
doing in this if you can't control what
other people are gonna say or whatever
other people in do yeah I think if I
learned that earlier I'd be and you know
save myself a lot to let life happen
yeah thank you guys for watching and we
really hope you found this helpful and
if you're suffering with a coyote we
hope this gave you the courage to seek
help
for more videos like this go to Grandma
UK's YouTube channel
you